hello and welcome to fundamental
investing with the aid of computers a
tutorial series number five so now that
we've brought in the price to book ratio
let's add another metric to screen with
so basically what I think what we'll do
is first we're gonna go through and
we've already done that so we go through
and find stocks only with a price to
book ratio that's less than 0.7 now of
those companies that we find let's look
for a priced earnings to growth for X
amount of time in this case Yahoo does
five years so that's what we're going to
do and we're gonna want to write a ratio
that's less than one so the idea of a
p/e G ratio is that a perfect one
represents a fair quote-unquote fair
value in accordance to price to earnings
to growth okay so not you wouldn't
necessarily want a price to earnings
number that's less than one always so
the purpose of adding growth into it is
that it kind of adds in that growth
factor right like if we've got a company
and we're expecting it to grow a bunch
of course our price to earnings is going
to be different than a company that we
don't expect any growth from for example
a lot of the companies that we're going
to find right now in the S&P 500 the
growth is going to be fairly minimal for
a lot of these companies some of the
companies will have a significant growth
but nothing compared to a company say
that's just had an IPO or something like
that right more closer to the category
of quote unquote startup right that's
the company is going to have massive
growth so with value investing we're
looking at the right now and we're
looking for companies that are currently
right now below what we would consider
fair value
so we're gonna be requiring the PDG to
be less than one good example of this
explanation of PE or someone to back up
this idea of PE to growth equaling one
is Peter Lynch in his one up on Wall
Street book he basically was you know
he's the one that said you know the p/e
ratio of a company that's fairly priced
is gonna equal its growth rate so if the
p/e ratio let's say the price to
earnings people are paying 10 times
earnings and the growth rate is 10
percent then now you have a fair priced
company but let's say the price to
earnings ratio is 10 but growth is 20
percent now we're cooking right we're
talking with a point 5 PG ratio so not
only do we want less than 1 but I kind
of think that we should exclude any
negative PE G ratio so the way you get a
negative PG ratio is that you're gonna
have negative growth so people are
paying maybe 10 times earnings but your
growth is minus 5% or expected to be not
minus 5% let's say so it's giving you a
negative 2 PE G ratio also your earnings
could decline and give you a negative B
eg personally I think that we should
find something with positive V G as we
are looking for a valued or a valuable
company that's just undervalued like our
goal is to look for an undervalued
company not look for a company that we
think might turn it around right that's
not what we're in the business of we're
looking for right now what's the value
of this company and is it undervalued
and so a company that maybe might turn
it around that's not good enough right
that's not the kind of investing we're
looking for when it comes to value
investing we might consider that down
the road with some of these other
fundamental investing strategies but
since we're doing value investing right
now it's best that we just avoid a
negative P G ratio in my opinion you
know a case can be made that negative P
eg you know for example something like a
company recognizes that it's stretched
too thin and kind of wants to bring it
in a little bit become more efficient
that's possibility but yeah for now I
think that we should just stick with an
above above zero
and also just keep in mind that even if
we do this you know we're nowhere close
to getting you know every stock that it
spits out as a good stock based on just
these these two factors right and then
also at the end of the day you're going
to want to compare p/e G's to companies
and related sectors since growth and
sectors can still vary greatly depending
on what sector we're comparing maybe and
as a value investor you're gonna want to
find the best valued company in a sector
that might you know pop if you're
expecting such a thing so now the apt a
bunch let's talk about doing it's gonna
be pretty close to what we did with the
price-to-book ratio we're gonna look
find it in that table and we're gonna
add it to our little program at use our
program to do a little bit of logic and
we'll we'll get this done so the first
thing we'll want to do is let's hop on
over to Yahoo again and here we have
we're just looking at a CI arch Cole and
the PE G ratio here we see is negative
0.76 so we're not too interested in it
but all we're gonna do right now is
figure out how we could find it on all
the stocks so again you're gonna want to
highlight what you're looking for view
the source find it there it is and so in
our case let's just we want to use
everything up to this point copy that
and we'll come back over to our script
and then just keep in mind it's again
it's a closing table data tag so I'm not
going to view this again for the other
side so we'll come back over to our
scripts and then again we're gonna we're
going to require that first off the
price to book ratio has to be under 0.7
so then we're going to just go ahead and
continue on but we're gonna say right
now PG 5 / PG of 5 years equals source
code split and again we're just going to
kind of do the same thing we did before
I'm gonna paste in that stuff that we
just found then we want the first
element there the first element think of
it as really the second element it's on
the other side of what we just use a
split and then we're gonna split again
by closing table data tags and in this
case we want the zero with element so
that should print out our PE G ratio so
let's try it real quick and so we should
get it for Alcoa so we'll save that run
it and drag this over here so anything
so we got a a so we want to get it for
Alcoa we got a the price to book ratio
for AAA is 0.66 and we didn't have a
printout peach I was like why isn't it
shouldn't spin it like instantly so then
let's just print PG 5 so go bring it
over okay so we got a a price to book
ratio is 0.66 the PG ratio sadly is
point R two point six four so we're not
too interested in it and then let's wait
for the other one
ACI and we already know that it's
negative 0.76 so if we come over here we
already did kind of confirm it just then
but let's look at hey here yeah it was
Alcoa and PG sure enough two point six
four so we did find the correct number
but obviously neither of these companies
passed the two requirements that we need
so bummer so now the next thing that we
want to do is first of all let's see if
we can find one in a short order I'll
run this this program for a little bit
and see if I see anything with the less
than one I'll pause it while I run it
okay so I went through the entire list
of the S&P 500 and the only stock that
meets this requirement was RadioShack
with a price to book ratio of 0.69 and a
PG 0.02 so what I'll do is we'll just
add R as H here
RadioShack comma and then what we can do
is for example do like if PG 5
and what we'll say is like great is
greater than zero yet less than one and
again we need to convert this to a flow
about the calves will just say you know
three stop comma meets requirements
something like that and then we'll
change this back to shore we won't print
that yeah print and then down here with
his print pbr3 ug5 and I put this in the
wrong one
hold on let's see can you follow or
removed this rsh because that was in
there on one and we'll add all right
eight there save that run it
and eventually I'll pause as it goes
through but shouldn't oh here it is
so it says you know RSH meets the
requirements first printed on our
price-to-book ratio than our PE G ratio
so that is adding another layer to our
stock screener obviously this added
layer shows us how hard it would be to
find a value investing stock in the S&P
500 using these two metrics though the
price book ratio was an okay one it was
the addition of the p/e G ratio that
really killed us here
so anyways we'll continue on with some
more principles for value investing as
always thank you for watching thank you
for your support your subscriptions and
until next time